[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc je m'appelle sylvie des vignes je
suis gérante de l'entreprise aux
couleurs du cheval qui est basée dans
l'eure en normandie et donc c'est ma
jument pomme avec qui je travaille
actuellement sur ce chantier
alors on avait deux types de travaux à
réaliser sur
sur ce chantier j'ai travaillé déjà la
semaine dernière sur le débusquage des
arbres morts qui ont été préalablement
abattu donc j'avais trois zones de
dépôts l'idée c'était vraiment de
dégager toute une zone pour ensuite
pouvoir faire des plantations
cette semaine je suis là avec pommes
pour le travail de sol donc
préparation pour les futures plantations
l'intérêt de travailler avec le cheval
que ce soit en débardage débusquage donc
sur le travail du bois ou sur le travail
du sol c'est vraiment la préservation
des sols le nom tassement on peut être
sollicitée en traction animale soit sur
des zones qui ont déjà des valeurs
environnementales donc des zones natura
2000 des espaces naturels sensibles ou
là le cheval vient vraiment conforté en
fait cette préservation de
l'environnement qui est déjà en place et
donc on peut intervenir aussi bien sûr
sur du débardage que par exemple sur du
fauchage
donc sur sur des périodes bien
spécifiques pour pertes pas perturber
les milieux
ici je pense que la demande est un petit
peu différent puisque on est pas sur un
ems on n'est pas sur une zone natura
2000 mais il ya vraiment une volonté de
restauration écologique du lieu
donc effectivement je travaille à côté à
côté des pelleteuses qui créent des
noues ce qu'en fait il y avait un gros
problème dans nos moments ici avec une
grosse problématique de mortalité des
végétaux là il ya un réaménagement de
fait donc bon c'est aussi intéressant de
voir qu'on peut combiner et l'action
mécanique et l'action du cheval mais
voilà je pense qu'il y avait sept cette
volonté de le pa2 de préserver le lieu
autant que possible